in this video we're going to introduce
the idea of a step response
this is one of the most common
occurrences in all of electronics and it
happens anytime there's some resistance
and some capacitance in series and in
particular it happens billions of times
a second inside every computer so that's
why we want to study this very carefully
so the step response is something that
happens in a circuit when we drive the
circuit with a step voltage that's a
step voltage shown right there
and this response is going to be related
closely
to the natural response
of an rc circuit
and if you haven't seen that video yet i
want to encourage you to take a moment
and go to watch the video on the rc
natural response
because i'm going to use that result
right here
now in the rc natural response what we
had was no energy going into a circuit
we had an rc circuit like this
and there was nothing
connected here so the source was removed
and we had
a c
and an r
and there was a voltage
on the original
capacitor there was some charge on this
capacitor right here
and we worked out what's the response of
the current
here and what's the response of the
voltage
v of t across this capacitor
and there we found that v of t
equals
v naught
times
e to the minus t over rc
so this is the natural response
of an rc circuit
and now what we're going to do in the
step response is we're going to actually
kick this circuit with a step we're
going to make the circuit do something
add some sort of stimulus from the
outside that pushes this rc circuit in
some direction and we're going to see
what that means and it's going to be
related to the natural response
so vs here starts at some voltage v
naught
then at time 0 right here
it makes a step a sharp step up to some
other
voltage step vs and what we want to do
is we want to see what this circuit does
and again we'll label this we want to
find out this v of t
so what's going to happen is and in the
past before t equals 0
this circuit will be in some state and
we'll figure out what that is and then
we're going to disturb the circuit and
it's going to settle down in some new
state and that's going to be called the
step response of the circuit
so our approach here is going to be to
look at this
first we're going to do this intuitively
and we'll just look at a long time ago
we'll look at
a long time from now well after the step
we'll see what the circuit's doing then
and then we'll look at what we'll guess
at what happens in between so first
we'll do this intuitively and then we'll
do it with the formal mathematics
so i said we're going to break it down
into three things the first first thing
we're going to look at is long ago
what was this circuit doing yesterday
when it was sitting here at v naught
well
long ago
v s
equals v naught
and what was going to happen is some
sort of current was going to flow out of
here and around into this capacitor and
it's going to leave some charge here
and that charge is going to pile up on
on the capacitor
and we know that it's related to
the voltage on the capacitor by cv
one of the things we're going to do as
we analyze this circuit is track what
happens to this q that's a that's a good
approach to thinking about what's going
on here
so if a long time ago vs was v zero
basically what happened some current
flowed
until
what till v here
reached v zero so
v equals
v zero
at some time in the past v became v
naught
and what happened to i then i
went to zero and the reason we know i
went to zero is because the voltage
across this resistor let me label it
like this
we'll call it vr
eventually this side was v naught and
this side became v naught
and z that's zero volts across the
resistor so that means the current goes
to zero
so this is the state a long time ago
i want to start sketching this
we'll do some time plots of this
and we'll make this i
and this v
and so we decided a long time ago
v was v naught
and the current we decided was zero so i
can put that on there like that
so that's our long time ago
next what we do is we go to super long
time let's get let's let t go to
infinity
that's a long time from now
and what's the state going to be then
well uh the vs is going to be
the source voltage is going to be vs
i'll
tell the part between capital letters
and lower case letters here capital
letters is a fixed voltage and vs is
something that changes with time
and we can do the same sort of analysis
where there's going to be some current
that will flow
q will build up until the voltage on the
capacitor
is
there'll be some current
the voltage on the capacitor
will go to
vs and the same story the voltage across
the resistor then will be zero again and
that means that i will be zero again
this is for a long time from now
so as we continue our intuition here a
long time from now
vs is going to be
the step voltage
big v s
and what's i going to be i we decided
was going to be 0.
so a long time from now out in the
future i is going to be zero again
okay
so now let's go back and look at what
happens between
okay this is in this is after the switch
happens and before a long time from now
and what we can guess what we can
estimate is that v naught is going to
become v s somehow
and that the current's going to start at
zero and it's going to do something and
it has to end up back at zero
okay let's get a little more detailed
let's make some a little better guesses
the moment after the step happens
the voltage on this side goes to vs
and the voltage on this side is what
well the charge is a bunch of charge
sitting here
on the capacitor and it hasn't had time
to go anywhere
so if that's the case then the voltage
right after the switch changes is going
to still be v naught
so that's going to be the voltage right
after here is not going to jump anywhere
and that's because we physically have
some charge stored on this capacitor and
it can't it has it hasn't had time to go
anywhere yet
that means on this side of the resistor
just after this the step happens this is
going to be v naught
oh look now i see now we have a voltage
difference across here so there's going
to be a current all of a sudden there's
going to be some current here let's
let's scribble that in let's see what
that does
there's going to be some sort of current
that happens
and it's going to be i is what it's
going to be v
s
minus
v naught
divided by r
that'll be the current
we'll label the current theorem that's
the current we're talking about all
right so we got our current to hop up
and now there's more charge as charge
flowing onto our capacitor so the
capacitor voltage is going to start
changing
more charge more voltage and what's
going to happen we can estimate this
it's going to just do
something like that
i can sketch that in
more and more charge will start flowing
onto this capacitor and the voltage will
gradually rise until
v equals
v s it's till the voltage across the
resistor again is zero and then the
current will stop
we had a sudden step of current
caused by the change in the step voltage
input and then it's going to just fade
out
something like that
until the current goes back to zero
v will go from
let's how do i write this let's we'll go
from v naught
and it will eventually become v s
and i
will have a step
and then
go back to zero
so that's our intuitive understanding of
how this
step response will look
for
a driven rc circuit
and next what we'll do is we'll work
this out
in detail and we'll get mathematically
accurate
versions of what these two curves look
like